Scudder: Hi.
I'm Jeff Scudder.
In this video, we'll be looking
at a couple of techniques
to improve the efficiency
of your App Engine applications.
The first thing we'll
be looking at is profiling,
which is a way to view
the execution path
taken through your app.
The second thing
we'll look at is memcache,
which is a way to speed up
the retrieval
of commonly used data.
To view
these two techniques,
we'll be looking
at the App Gallery
sample application.
Let's take a look.
Now we're looking
at the App Gallery application.
This app shows
featured applications,
editors' picks,
and the most recently added
applications.
This version of the code
doesn't include
any profiling code.
So we're going to show
how to add that
to get an idea of which pieces
of the application
are being exercised
when we view the pages.
To learn
how to do profiling,
we'll look in the Frequently
Asked Questions section
on code.google.com/appengine.
We show two ways to add
profiling to your application.
We're going to go
with the second one,
which adds the profiling data
to the logs.
Now we see the main function
of the App Gallery's code.
We're going to add
our profiling function here.
To add profiling,
we've replaced the main function
with this profile_main.
This captures profiling data
and pushes it into the logs.
I've uploaded a new version
of the App Gallery application,
which now includes
profiling.
You can see
that the application
looks exactly the same
as before.
But now, if we look
on the admin console,
we can see profiling data
in the logs.
Here in the dashboard,
I'm viewing version 4
of the App Gallery,
which includes
profiling data.
Let's take a look
at the logs.
Here we see the profiling
data from the logs
that show the path
that's taken
through our
application's code.
Right around here,
we see some calls
to entity.pb,
which is responsible for working
with the, uh, data models.
Quite a bit of time
is spent in our application
working with these data models
from the datastore.
And we can improve some of this
by adding memcache.
Let's take a look at how
this version of the application
is fetching data
from the datastore.
I'm pulling up the main page
of the application
and viewing the get_or_fetch_
main_page method.
You can see here
that we're querying
for the top apps,
recent apps,
and the featured
application,
and then plugging these values
into our template.
Now, these same queries
are repeated
each time we view
the main page.
The results don't change
all that often.
So querying every time
is a little bit expensive.
Since the results
are always the same,
we could see a vast improvement
by adding memcache,
which stores recent results
in memory.
Let's take a look
at adding that now.
I can take this same
main page class
and add in memcache.
In the get_or_fetch_main_page
method,
I'm first calling
a memcache.get,
which tries to fetch
recent results from memcache.
If the results
are in memcache,
I'll return them
immediately.
Otherwise, I'll perform
the datastore queries
as I did before.
After I construct the values
to put into the template,
I add them to the cache
so that next time I make a call,
I can use the cache values
instead of calling
to the datastore.
After making these changes,
I've uploaded version 5
of the application.
Once again, you can see
that the application
looks exactly the same.
All of the changes
are under the hood, so to speak.
If we look at version 5
of the application
in the dashboard,
we can see that there's
been an improvement
in performance of some
of the commonly fetched pages.
For example, if we compare
the average CPU
to previous versions,
this number has decreased.
If we look at the logs,
we can also see that some data
is coming out of memcache
instead of the datastore.
Here's a log entry
for viewing the main page.
You can see that calls
are now being made to memcache
instead of the datastore.
This should greatly improve
the efficiency
of our application.
Now you've seen how to add
profiling to your application
and how to use memcache.
These are just two
of the many ways
to speed up your application,
and we'll be covering more
in the future.
Stay tuned.